we know you found it inconvenient so
other people upon the other thing in
comedian I mean oh you know I don't say
that right so we need to support exactly
that that's what's my point so it's not
that our commercial is bad is that we
need something for us to do so so yeah
that's two solution kind of that emerge
two contenders one will be a function
like a radius you know what you put
whatever function you want your two
arrays and your convention or maybe an
extension of the convention maybe this
can be some level there that's the
things that telly is been thinking about
the other one would be a wrapper around
the function sorry sorry no no so
everyone is a wrapper around the array
that was Telus original suggestion and
it's actually not so bad it has once yes
good idea yeah there's one small issue
but it's not really English you depend
how you see it is that Plus can have
many argument and so you see yeah you
have an example with three arguments
here and it has to be done in the order
that doesn't fail like there's always an
order that works and that's fine and
although that fails I think that's a
good idea I think it's much better than
doing it on the operation in other words
it's a it's a it's a it's a kind of a um
absorption I don't know what though but
this is this is a bad word but absorb
okay it's it's more than extension how
are you can extend yourself I don't know
I guess you can see both sides right but
the question is does this become this
becomes kind of a list absorber
by the way first people who might be
rejoining this livestream some technical
issue there we made great progress while
you are away on the array reduce
function and we will bring that back to
a subsequent meeting when we have a
preliminary implementation okay so I
think that's a really good idea that the
wrapper around the object itself is a
really good idea and so okay the
objective is that if you have something
like this and you say plus X Y okay what
you want is to add the X Y to the lowest
level yep and so the idea here would be
X Y right right right so what we would
say is something like plus inserted or
something and then actually I like your
top and bottom you know we've been
thinking of I mean when you don't put a
second argument it would be that inverse
of our convention I believe but then you
could specify the type of we have a
second argument and that could be like
top bottom because you kind of extend
yourself from the top low although you
apply a top level or you apply at the
bottom level well that's called level
one or level minus one exactly yeah but
then can we generalize to other levels
maybe I think so
maybe I don't see why not I think it's
part of an array reduce story I think
this is just a notation for array reduce
so so I think the operation which is in
the line here is something which is used
tons of times it's a version of
transpose similar to rotate to rotate
left and rotate right so we do many
times you have an very deep array you
rotate it many times so that the deepest
level is first you do some operation and
you rotate it back yeah yeah
that's how we do in practice either we
use a map if we have a memory constraint
we use a map if we have a time
constraint we use to transpose that's
typically how it is implemented
all we have a special function to the
weight internal so still fine I mean
it's something like every transpose left
transpose right for all following rotate
left take point act in the Transpo space
yeah that's right I mean really what it
is is it's a we thought about it
transposed rock trance at some point
well so you're saying this would be on
an array would it's more like this
transpose applied just like we have
reverse applied still I'm saying so
reverse applied of f of XY is that this
looks like the array reduce which looks
like a reduce transposed apply no no
apply did the did to done it's a
headdress
to address its address but yeah the
operation looks like yeah well now it's
in the blast not in there seemed to be
of it right so wait a minute this is a
different thing this is the thing which
could be useful in its own right okay
this is I don't quite understand the
operation this is basically apply F at
the lowest level
by the way you know there's a question
of the curried form of a array reduce
yep which which could perfectly well be
array reduce F level definitely and then
array yep
okay but I want to come back to this one
I think this is not completely unrelated
to spliced right because if we say 2x3
well two three four slash dot I don't
know why it's exactly opus the three
pausing craziness spliced no it's just
splice which is very nice by the way
that idea it's something a little bit
like that it's like saying you know
because this is an atom so it's actually
going to do exactly the right thing so
I'm saying if this was effectively a
splice it would do exactly the right
thing kind of conceptually if if plus
was Auto splicing it would do the right
thing but I believe we really should add
these other splicing functions well but
we would have the same problem as before
how many levels do we want it to burrow
well we wouldn't have in this case
because because we already have to find
that right so if we do this for five
plus well it's through the five six plus
splice of XY right that will already do
that but if the first was how I feel
that's three
you have to splice twice alright it
doesn't do the right thing it does
almost the right thing okay but it's a
concept like this it's saying treat this
as an atom I see no it doesn't quite
work I see what you're saying so this
has to go to a certain level so it could
look inside there and find out this
thing is some number of levels from the
bottom so do this yeah I really like
this idea I really like this idea this
is gonna be very nice because that's the
right way to think about it as well yeah
even either a second argument right
saying insert one in this case comma one
in other cases it will be insert this
twice I don't think it neither I think
it has an easy default which is make it
do the right thing I mean in other words
make it do the in the opposite of the
convention yeah typically for example if
the first one was there if the first one
is lips four and the insertion has depth
to what does it do
so the first array has dimensions 2 2 2
2
yeah it's dangerous if it's automatic it
would fail if it cannot ha well okay but
I mean this one here plus insertion two
to insertion XY I think that could
perfectly well notice that okay so the
the more complicated case will be this
what does it do then well I was thinking
if the first array was already 2 by 2 by
2
it's not clear at which of the two so we
want to do this son
I suit you say well ok so the default
could be at the bottom level okay if
it's - bye - bye oh yeah yeah no no
there's two levels to do it again this
is how quantity array works doing or
operations at the deepest level it cut
oh very interesting
ok so wait a minute wait a minute
analogy with quantity array I didn't
know that
so Quincy to Ray takes an array of no.3
- - and then it says meter seconds
that's referring to the deepest level
because it can't do anything else it's
gotta be numbers well this array it can
be symbols it doesn't matter what you
put in the ring as long as it's October
right but you were saying the the
specification of units applies where
it's a deepest level so if you say X
comma Y 1 comma 2 or whatever
Oh array of lists of quantities with
units right where each sub list at the
very bottom level has units blah blah
blah blah blah blah except
okay so these requires quite a lot of
infrastructure inside to do threading
and multiple other operations at the
deepest level I understand this is a
brilliant idea and my opinion this thing
here I mean there are details to work
out but this is the right way to go
much better than head dressing anything
or anything like that it's the right
place to put that concept you know it's
it's it's it's nice yeah we just miss it
a little bit because of this you know
then you have to do the pressure in the
right order if you have to plus voila
but I well I guess now now add on the
right-hand side plus and I don't know
press one two three
mm yeah that's a good point
so if insertion has two possible arrays
into which it can be inserted very
different things yeah I mean it cannot
in that case being that it can only be
entered in on the left one so the
operation has to be first right on the
first two element and then no please one
doesn't work no don't work so this
operation hold on this this thing here
that would work right this thing yeah no
because then there's a third thing yeah
well what would you like this to do this
will fail no I understand but I mean you
know in you know in some language where
it defaults store some library a package
or whatever it is where it defaults to
what does it do for this case what does
it do oh did you think of that if you
remove two eight eight then this is good
no no I don't care about that I'm asking
in this vaunted scheme where somebody is
claiming that we should have done it the
other way around
what does this case do I mean I think no
one may give a result for that so we all
fail oh okay okay fine good just just
making it clear that you know it's not I
don't know what kind of attorneys not
bad at all
it's actually just me Advent it as you
say like rag the Ray it's really good
yeah it doesn't need to do it the other
way around sometimes right which is it
which is why this is a brilliant idea to
have a wrapper around the insertion so
to speak well but I like this fact that
this is not commutative
so we would be releasing already
it already got that assumed plus our
plus is not community visit well plus
itself it is it's just that it's used in
other cases like dates for example in
which it's not commutative if I guess
will be the same you know that's it
that's a complicated issue but I think
we can handle it I think it's better to
make this work than to preserve the
pluses always commutative
yeah users will have to be careful with
parentheses like they're already cases
where does it an issue with that with
list ability isn't there already a case
for list ability where you have to where
it matters I think there is so look
there's complicated semantics for this
thing and at what level it inserts at
and how that all works but I think this
is going to be really nice made more
progress than our thoughts same here
right I thought this was going to be a
horrible mess but that that's a
brilliant idea
um and I just think this whole family of
things from nothing to splice to
whatever these things that use a
symbolic wrapper to say what to do when
the thing arrives is really a good idea
I mean we've got we've got two new meta
ideas in recent years one is headdresses
and the other is some you know this
notion of I know what we call them
symbolic payload functions right I think
it's kind of a new idea this symbolic
payload that kind of you know deploys on
arrival if that makes sense which
nothing was probably the first example
of that but I really like this idea I
think we should really look at we should
look at transpose applied or whatever it
should be called as well so we've got
three things here we've got
arrey reduce got a preliminary version
we got this thing we should try and
figure that version that we should get
transpose applied that was very
productive I think it's a very important
functions great and um I I think the
name of a reduce is quite reasonable
yeah yeah I'm just wondering what people
think with reduce like I know like you
know in Map Reduce this sort of thing
like in parallel computing world which I
guess it's also doing a miss doing now
yeah so okay it's close enough to be
good to have comments on people that are
yeah yeah we should get covered they say
no ready something completely different
you get it right I would say let's play
with it first because for example we
have tensor reduce it's such a similar
name and doing such a different thing no
we are fair enough okay fine yeah okay
um since we're on a roll I want to just
have a look at these other things here
I'm right the so um and do you have Nick
yes yes I I made it back yeah okay um
all right just I'm sorry I'm just I'm
actually very pleased with this that's
good okay all right okay
very nice all right um we have a pretty
preliminary rough page for this to do I
need to load my documentation I know I
haven't updated it super recently so if
you have anything from the past week it
should be fine
but the idea of the function here is
that we have date value which is an
extractor for lots of information about
dates and one potential use for that
information is to have a counterpart
function of date select where I can take
any of those dates
elements and say this is a criteria I
have for selection so I have this big
collection of dates or this date
interval and I want to pull out all of
them that happen on Wednesday or all of
them that are in April and we've been
looking at different ways of handling
those this applies with scheduling with
recurring dates and holidays and trying
to come up with an expressive language
that lets us do pretty straightforward
things of you know day of the week month
of the year and potentially more
complicated things where we have
alternatives so in a lot of holidays
you'll have but also you might have a
date interval is your first argument
right yeah and so so then you're
implicitly taking a select from that yep
and there's a particular granularity
extraction - if I have an interval that
skint a continuous period of time I may
want back you know some sub interval of
that from the selection or I may want
every day within that interval that
matches the criteria for every hour
depending on the city but that's
different okay so in other words the
question is are you coming back with a
concrete list of elements of granularity
X mm or are you coming back with sub
intervals right that that is a thing
we've been thinking about with data
interval but don't have a concrete
answer for it
the most useful result kind of differs
depending on the use case of whether
your date interval itself has a
granularity because data intervals can
have implicit granularity or if you have
a continuous interval and what element
no it's good question whatever happened
with our temporal logic project Jose do
you want to take that one continue this
is a case in which John got too busy
with his University and it's not that we
have abandoned it but I thought it
didn't go completely in the right
direction
initially yes we started in a direction
which were
too much into logical stuff and you
didn't like it and when it was the time
to reconsider and restart in a different
direction he was too easy
so we didn't get we should look at it
again yep I wonder if there's anything
that can be taken from that and put in
the function repository at the least
finds me talking of function repository
in the discussion we had about category
theory yesterday we talked a bunch about
type theory and so on
and I just wonder whether there's
anything from that symbolic types
project that you did a while ago could
that turn into something that is either
in the packet repository on the function
repository well I think it would be more
like a bucket so I that could weary
implemented as extensions of the
compiler type framework yes and I think
it would be the most appropriate place
to put it on Kraft fine all right so the
question here is what's up just go ahead
sorry I was going to say that this is a
bit like the entity implicit entity
framework to select stuff from the
entities so we do things efficiently for
rates where you're saying we can say
hash something rather exactly rather
than property our own value we would say
hash property equals very and then we
can use logic combinations so you say
hash month whatever so your your concept
is that what I might say to be more
concrete here I might say maybe you have
examples there select day tenth of all
blah blah blah blah blah hash month
equals equals but hash month number
equals equals hash month what the heck
is it is there is there an entity for
April
no this would have to follow the
conventions used for the date string
elements or delayed value elements okay
is that right Nick yes that's a string
yeah that's the framework we have right
now no date value now come a month mmm
oh boy yeah and we the convention and
date value Falls what we've had in date
strings so there's month month name
month name short etc so there would have
to be a month entity well our notion
immediately with this was to use named
slots and have those aligned with the
element names and day value really yeah
I don't know how complicated it would be
to take every date value elements and
turn those results into their own entity
domains
you know we could have months for we
could have an entity for every month but
the months are also different on
different calendars we could have a lot
of them are just numeric values so the
when we say you know the fifth week it's
referring to a standard representation
of the fifth week of a Gregorian year
and sorry I I don't think we need
entities we could create a month entity
yeah we could I think we should but but
I don't think we need it by default
right so we follow what about eight
value does and we might want to repeat
some numbers like month number yeah but
I mean month name I could perfectly well
say here month name equals equals June
and then I could say something like hash
month greater than six yep hmm I like
this this is quite nice I think so there
are two design challenges that I haven't
been a
to sort out yeah one of the big ones is
being able to handle the enth instance
within a given cycle so for example you
know holidays often appear on the third
Thursday in November or something like
that it's necessary to do them
computationally generally how that's
been done in the past is that under the
hood we'll say it needs to be Thursday
and the day of month needs to be greater
than this value in less than this value
which we can on our live stream about
other discussion we came up with a just
to let you know sorry that some things
went down don't worry
broadcasting is dead we have a much
better idea for how to do it so I put
that in brackets because it's not
broadcasting it's it's it's a way of
inserting things into a sublevel in
addition to a list we'll be bringing it
back in another meeting it's very cool
they're very pleased with ourselves
we've made great progress while we were
off the air so to speak although the if
you really curious what we figured out
this is this the recording will be
available um okay so you're saying the
third yeah so in terms is saying select
from the date interval let me take a
specific example select from the day
tenth of all the third Wednesday yeah
well I've got an idea
um okay so here's here's a question if
I've got able to save those unless I put
these someplace else um okay so let's
say that I have a list and I want to say
select from the list and I've got the
list I don't know
our range 20 range 20 and I want to
select let's say I say prime Q okay
great what happens if I want to say I
want to select only the third prime Q or
prime Q's after the third one we don't
have a mechanism for that right now but
we could did you know in case we need
here is 2/3 something after something ok
but so this would be the third thing
that matches or worse
the third thing after x that matches
yeah this is done like in cron notation
this tends to be done with division so
you'll have like in the day of the week
is Thursday divided by 3 so it happens
every third Thursday within the the
interval that Cron's notating which by
the way we are we are supporting cron
notation right Croy notation is
supported in scheduling yes a scheduled
task has a but we should we should
support we should just like we have
regular expression we should say
something like cron of or cron chronics
Russian or something and then we should
just support one of these weird things
what's an example of one so you might
have like asterisks it depends on the
use case because for a lot of cron
notations you don't it's not reducing to
a specific date and we don't have a
general notation for sort of a
quote-unquote headless State that's part
of what date select is looking towards
okay but I still think we should support
cron expression or just like regular
especially you can type whatever junk
you expect from cron and then yeah I
think there definitely makes sense okay
so what you're asking for is the third
Wednesday so okay so this is all
beautiful so now
the question is how to notate what what
is the cron notation for it
so let's it may be easier to put in the
zoom chat I'm not sure okay so that's an
example that basically is looking for
the it all weekdays during the tenth
month of the year so the asterisk is
basically a variable yeah so and there
are different forms of chrono tation but
quartz notation is what we're using
little explain this notation to me so
the a string is yes any then month then
day then hour and then the second day of
week oh so that's a Fifth Element yeah
so you're saying that in their notation
its month year month day blah blah blah
maybe hour minute second yeah and they
also include a day of week because a lot
of scheduling is concerned with days of
weeks so for like brilliant financial
instruments you only want your stuff to
run on business days or yo boy it's so
weird how all these design choices
whoever designed weeks and another
Babylonians or somebody the you know it
just so spirals into all this crud in in
them yeah I mean that's a very weird
construct that okay sander on our live
stream is say is thinking it has a piece
of code that could nominally get the
third
yeah that right I mean so that could be
so the first argument in there yeah
would select I thought I've got a
concern here if I say date value now oh
boy there's a mess here we're gonna have
to okay hold on and then I say day of
week day Oh day is three but what's the
day of the week so Dame named by default
is uh okay what is that is that a string
so our default here is oh noes the day
named fun cool actually a symbol I'm
good
okay let's fly this thing string if you
need okay terrific that will work fine
then this will work given that we've got
symbols for the days of the week yep
okay it's a little weird we don't have
symbols for the month of the year I
think the we talked about at one time
and looked at potentially having it and
there was a question about whether may
as a symbol would be useful somewhere
else oh God oh you know I'm telling you
the hackery language is so full of hacks
and I mean we haven't used it in the
past 25 years
so now that doesn't mean anything it's a
short word yeah I have it would be a
mistake to use it um
okay so the main issue I have with the
the notation appointment this isn't even
correct is this correct several takes
effort yeah which would work if you just
had if you're just looking for that
specific instance within the month but
if you want to pick out you know
Memorial Day and you have an arbitrary
interval the third Monday that it comes
across in May may not actually be
Memorial Day because your interval may
start partway through May and so the
hard thing is that we want to say it's
the enth instance of this within this
cycle so internally and like the
calendar framework we have these notions
of repeating cycles so all you know most
calendars went on a seven-day week cycle
some run on 10-day or otherwise but we
want to be able to run the enth instance
after this day is generally how we
represent it within the operation we're
doing in calendars and within the date
framework but it hasn't proven to be
easily expressible in language the same
way that just saying the element number
is you know it needs to be a Wednesday
and it needs to be in June is a lot
easier to express than it needs to be
the third Wednesday within the cycle of
June what do you mean by the cycle of
June I mean isn't it within June yeah
it's it's within June but again the the
issue being if I have a date interval
that starts today or I have a date
enroll that starts tomorrow and goes for
a month and I say give me the third
Wednesday from that interval it's not
actually going to be the third Wednesday
in June it'll be the fourth one because
the interval started partway through
June
why aren't you saying
right so dates select is saying of the
Centreville pick out the things that
match this criterion right right what
you're now saying is um what what um so
I think that the specific functionality
we're looking for is basically an
instance of something after some date so
if we went to the third Wednesday in
June we would say I want this you know
an instance of something would be I want
the third Wednesday after June 1st on or
after June 1st why isn't this some kind
of don't we have some kind of day plus
State plus thing
what does date plus do so date plus does
have step sizes so we can generate these
relatively easily it's mostly that it's
hard to combine those different date
elements into individual criteria
element don't we just need some kind of
wrapper I'm not quite seeing it yet um
it's kind of weird construct that we
have that process work with with day
types Nick yeah so date bus does work
with day types so you know if you wanted
to say I want to get okay so let's see
so here step size so n so if I say 4
steps off to date so if I were to say I
mean I'm just trying to understand
whether that would work whether that
could conceivably work yeah that will
get you does it get me something right
now mm-hmm yep why does that work that
works because we've expanded support in
de+ to include day types which includes
days of the week do you say that here oh
yeah okay so this this gives you the
third Wednesday you're saying what it
doesn't do is the third Wednesday within
a particular range right but we already
have then a syntax here for specifying
third Wednesday so now we just have to
be able to say within a date interval
mmm give me the third Wednesday yeah so
isn't that a different construct don't
we have a construct like that within a
date enter will give me the
such-and-such how do we do that within a
date enter will give me this might work
so if we had date brush of hash commas
through Wednesday and around it sounds
like date value month equals June
that would be the third Wednesday angel
yeah I suppose it's complicated but yeah
well okay so but we've already got a
notion of the third Wednesday after
right so now we've I need need to say
the third Wednesday within right so if
this was a granular object okay so let's
say that let's say that was the whole
year okay yes current date year okay so
there's so let's imagine it was this and
we did something like that it's a little
weird but it's something of that type
mm-hmm so now in the case of dates
select how would this be used in date
select how do you do sub casings so it
enter current year I want the months of
current year how do I get that did so
I'm saying yeah doesn't that date range
maybe increment from that yeah I don't
know whether we'll accept this for date
one day - yeah it doesn't get the moment
splat for ooh okay I should probably
work but but in this idea of within a
particular
is commenting the deep within it's
basically date selected I I don't think
it is quite well is it what's the
relationship between dates selecting
date within it's very similar yeah I
think it's pretty similar um although if
we did use the date within name it would
allow us to not support necessarily
things that are so so much like select
but it depends look this thing this last
thing here you know the difficulty is if
we want both this and we want the third
Wednesday in every month after six right
so then we would end up in something
very weird hash month hash month greater
than six is beautiful
mmm okay so now the question is what do
we want to do so then Wednesday that is
third um I mean we could potentially
I've thought about having a date element
name which is basically a day name and
instance within the month pair so it
will give back for the first Wednesday
of the month it'll give one comma
Wednesday and for the fourth instance
that would give four comma Wednesday but
sorry how do I get the third Wednesday
of this month um so I mean that's
basically what the the date plus if you
did nobody this month how do I get I
want to know third Wednesday of this
month right that's that's the thing
you're asking for here so I mean this is
it's some kind of ordinal date thing
it's almost a concept you're saying
okay so so it would be I this isn't
quite right but the ordinal dates select
it's not quite right the interval the
day tenth of all right the thing you're
selecting and the ordinal test so the
ordinal test might be three is less than
hashes less than six or maybe it's a
pattern I don't know
that means Wednesday's between the third
and the seventh I'm surprised that this
kind of concept of things between the
third and the seventh or whatever
right so so what's the general concept
out outside the framework of dates this
is similar to take after we had
discussed take after take through after
something that's right the
pointing out that the third argument of
select would give you the third I mean
would solve this particular problem but
I don't think it's a general solution
right so in other words it's it's not a
great solution I mean we could imagine
in here we could imagine that we could
have a I mean I don't know why select
doesn't allow a list there to give just
the third element right and we we need
something that is a boolean because we
might want to have the third after
something or this second after sensing
no I know I know I know it's like like
the date where you know where it's both
this and that type thing and even worse
than that I could imagine you know the
the the fourth blue moon of the next
century right where where some of those
things might be or the the fourth
eclipse of the next century or something
right there is there are these
postponement rules in their Jewish
calendar things can be that day or that
day and if they are the day then the
next one will be some other thing Oh
interesting okay
well I mean I guess there are rules I
mean it's just like well when do we get
to do leap seconds by the way we are
working on calendars now and that's an
orthogonal thing which is the time
systems a bit like the difference
between projects projections and atoms
in the Geo framework yeah well remember
we have at least one set of customers
for that my friends in the deep space
program yeah I mean cuz that's a case
where all of this stuff will get I
wouldn't earth do we do there are you're
saying we just decide on the time system
and then we're operating on all these
selectors within that time system is
that the idea exactly yeah we just say
our time is atomic time and we just
counting seconds as they count or our
time system is UTC and we can seconds as
they count which is some days have more
seconds than others and none of the
things we're doing here will mess up no
I don't think so if they are just
independent it's just that the the the
end of a year counting one time system
does not coincide with the end of some
other yeah whereby year we mean 365
point two four eight one whatever it is
days no what I mean is that if we say
the 2nd of February of this day that day
counting in this time system is
different from some other time system by
a few seconds oh I see
all right I'm we probably should okay
[Music]
saundra so he doesn't see why third
argument doesn't solve this
the problem is that if we want to then
do logic with respect to that third
Wednesday we're kind of stuck if there's
just a third argument
or you have a very long interval so I
have you know 300 years and I want to
pull out the third Wednesday in
September for all of them if I just have
the third argument of select and say
three I'm just gonna grab the third
instance of it all right but I'm still
I'm still looping on the question of
hash month gives you wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute there's an easier
way to do this what if what if there was
an attribute that was called um let's
see
okay I know this is a stupid name but
I'm gonna call it anyway month
ordinal Wednesday actually no no no no I
just has to say month
ordinal so in other words this says in
date value right if I said month
ordinal it will say of this day of the
week which number is young fact wsh has
on our live stream suggested something
almost identical to this
so month week no that doesn't work month
week doesn't work month week is there a
month week already I know there isn't
currently okay but there could be a
month week so month week could be the
which week number
depending on how it starts which week
number is this in the month but it
depends how it starts here we have a
week of the year that's just it's just
um which week number is this in the
month right that's the bit but what I'm
suggesting is this notion of a month for
ordinal month
ordinal day or something um which simply
is the answer to this question which
serial number in the month in the
current month is this day see what I'm
saying so I claim with that you could
just do this we had that extra date
value we could just do this on we could
just answer this third Wednesday today
would be one Wednesday it'd be the first
no no no that this would be okay so the
value today would be one right because
it says it is the first Wednesday right
so this says okay so month
ordinal day bad name not quite the right
name yet is this means means which
instance of this day of the week is a
particular day is is a particular date
within this month I see so Sunday would
still be one but Monday would be 2
because it's the second Monday within
this month what are you talking about
we're on June 3rd yeah so we're on June
3rd so this coming Sunday is the seventh
and it's the first Sunday within the
month so it's not the water right but so
if we went back to last Saturday
Saturday would be like four or something
whatever it is because it is the fourth
it actually be Saturday but there'd be
the fifth instance okay fine I'm not
looking at a calendar
well actually that that would be called
it could be called des instance Dame
name is usually what we've referred to
so it could be de name instance or ICJ
name well it's really in the month
what's what's the analogous thing here
so this is
you
this is a good way to handle us in my
opinion I mean it shouldn't be hard to
put I think it's very very easy I mean
this is this is like super easy and we
and this is handling this particular
awkward case of the enth Wednesday now
so the enth Wednesday after such and
such a date not clear how you handle
after such and such a date oh actually
yes it's very easy just say greater than
bla bla bla yeah it works beautifully
right you're just saying dates select
right if you say the third Wednesday
after law okay so then we would say
current year current date of year okay
so third Wednesday after
december's well
particular date you want to put it in
here but the third Wednesday after the
new moon
you know we're gonna need things like
things about lunar calendar in here
because if we could get that those are
the only things anybody pays attention
to right if we if we had date value
properties that were lunar date value
Luna we've got astrological sign for
goodness sake mm-hmm don't we just have
the new moons certainly we are going to
be adding them because we will need them
for the yeah the the other complication
which we don't need to dive into here
since I know we're running over is that
sometimes we may want to specify the
criteria in a different calendar so for
Easter it's easier to represent Easter's
date in the ecclesiastical calendar or
if I have holidays that appear on the
Hindu lunar calendar why don't we wrap
the original date oh I see because you
don't want to see you yeah and I think
it probably we just need some decoration
that says these criteria are
specifically using calendar X instead of
calendar Y and we just need some
decoration to say I want I see you know
I heard some kind of calendar relative I
don't know how we're representing the
calendars in general I mean but you're
saying we want a rapper that says you
know calendar block or something roughly
something like that so that says the
things within this represent a
correspond to this calendar yeah I went
we're gonna want the same thing for time
system by the way hmm how do we do that
in geo and geo we have
notion of a geo position with a with a
datum right yes that's the second
argument of CEO position or geogrid we
could say so yes so I think we could do
that same thing here we could have these
things like de name take a second
argument which is their calendar and I'm
NBD lost in this part of the discussion
okay so we're saying look for example
let's say it's the month name okay but
you want it for the Jewish month name
for example you want to give a criterion
on with the standard calendar right
but with a but you want to say I don't
even know my but you know with it with a
Jewish month name you want to say the
first day of Jewish month such-and-such
with respect to my ordinary calendar
right so yes so the way we are planning
to do these is that by having dead value
to be an extractor and not having any
conversion capabilities so if you want
to extract the month the Jewish month
you first have to convert your date to
add to a Jewish calendar how do you do
that how do you do that kind of converts
comma Jewish oh I see so in other words
and the in the date select you would say
calendar convert comma Jewish and then
outside of that you would say date value
whatever exactly yep
you would have to specify I want to do
this separation in this kinda so Canada
is another correct but but the case that
we keep on looping on is this you know
third Wednesday in the month and I think
that can be simply solved by by this by
having this value I'm thinking about
that so I think this is assuming that
there the third Wednesday is the
Wednesday of the third week and that I'm
not sure because the weekend but we need
to two versions of this I agree with you
we need two versions we need look the
third Wednesday the Wednesday of the
third week is different from the third
Wednesday okay so I mean but I think we
can name though
okay Wednesday of third week I don't
think that's the common thing Wednesday
third week I don't think is the versus
actually third Wednesday isn't what when
they I don't know these all these rules
about you know when is Memorial Day I
isn't it that second one that's being
used yeah it's it within holidays it's
almost always the second one almost
always I can't say categorically because
I haven't looked at all calendars but
every instance I know of it is always
yesterday how are we doing at taking our
extensive curation from the wolf mal for
holiday data system and putting that in
the language so we have some shared data
in the holiday calendar framework and
I've asked Alan and Rodrigo a couple of
times about exposing it through entity
value and that kind of stalled out I
need to poke them about it again and
push them I mean you know we obviously
want you know beaver day or whatever the
heck all these all these crazy things
are yeah I think we talked about having
it be like special day data or something
fine but you know that well it just
needs to be an entity I think it can be
in the entity framework
mm-hm and I mean that's a little the
silliest of those things is you know
whatever I'm out all day or something
yeah yeah all day that's a good one
we're also looking into their their
holidays for a stock exchanges yes those
we I thought we had those I mean we have
them a wolf an alpha yeah we do have
them in the language they're not
comprehensive for every exchange and
they I see alright but okay but so the
actually third Wednesday I mean the
Wednesday over the third week is easy to
get that's just hash week equals three
hash day day name equals Wednesday right
this one here is hash we
equals three and hash de name equals
Wednesday okay that that the third
Wednesday the actually third Wednesday I
mean look one possibility is instance in
month no I mean it's very long day name
instance and month I mean if you saw
that you at least know what it is yeah
we can prototype with that and then
condense it to something a little better
if we think on it a little bit fine
I don't think that's bad day name
instance a month I mean it's a
complicated concept and this would this
will will have autocomplete so at least
makes fine a little easier to finally
alright
we should play wrap up here unless
there's some other quick thing I'm okay
we were very productive here doesn't I
tells loss of the Internet something
whatever happened anyway in case
anybody's really curious as I say we the
recording should contain the did what we
said when nobody was listening type
thing
great okay thanks guys see you later
thank you